[Music]
well
have you guys heard about gwen stefani
no but i haven't heard her about her in
a while she's so hot
you said no but i haven't heard about
her for a while yeah
she's on that singing show with her
husband right yeah uh well they're not
married
they're not married they're engaged why
are all these yeah so
trey atkins or some [ __ ] he has one of
those cowboy names that's right
yes exactly just kidding blake shelton
lake shelton that's a cowboy name
very california i've ever heard of one
yeah it could also be like a
english agent of the espionage or
something like the shells
i didn't open my mind like that right
lucky gotta think more globally
sometimes steve
sorry not everything revolves around
america
or texas yeah it does all right so gwen
she's now 51 years old but she's not for
divorce
from her husband of 13 years
she's 51 yeah
his name is gavin rossdale he's 54
and they got divorced or like she fell
for divorce back in
august of 2015 and it was finalized in
april of 2016 but in 2015
she started dating blake shelton and
so now very publicly by the way that's a
lot like everyone knew the whole time
yeah so this is her husband her count
dracula
great yeah so it was a blood sucker it's
a spooky presence
yeah i don't like him no she's with
blake shelton she looks great for physio
she looks photoshopped it's [ __ ]
everything she's in it's crazy like she
never ages
she's hers yeah she's gorgeous oh i like
that guy too
yes what does he do i have no idea in
commercials honestly
he's like that's why he's got a cowboy
name he has a warm presence though
yeah yeah yeah so they've been together
for since
the beginning of her divorce from the
other guy i imagine him riding horses
very slow
probably so the divorce has been final
for almost five years i guess
and and then now the reason why we're
talking about it is because
just recently the catholic church
granted an annulment of her first
marriage and so now because like
her religion's really oh because she did
it through the catholic church
her priest married her and uh gavin
well she's catholic yeah she's catholic
and so the reason why
she hasn't gotten married to blake is
because
like she's been hoping and waiting for
this annulment from the catholic church
so then her priest could
could marry them and so now it's been
granted
is the pope gonna come down is that what
she's waiting for
not the pope but it was made by the the
decision was made by the vatican
tribunal why did it have to go so high
and why does it take so long
do they use scrolls that's the pokemon
married people that'd be sick
i thought they're too busy dealing with
the lawsuits from the kids
i think that they made those go away
what kids oh the vatican i thought you
meant she was i was like what
no i don't know well yeah but i mean
good for
them now they can get married and
like they're probably gonna speed things
up man she was the [ __ ]
[ __ ] the og stuff but then like when she
went solo and started to
like went kind of like harajuku girls
and rediscovered herself
oh what was she i wasn't really with
that you know you weren't
no no no no well maybe because like we
are different in age so like
people usually like the artist at the
time they got introduced to them true
right
so like for me it was like the [ __ ]
scott
orange county like that branding i
really liked and i thought she was going
to
go further into that direction but she
started like
inventing [ __ ] which is not bad more
like hip-hop you're disappointed in her
direction that were that was my taste
right
if she took it yeah i mean i mean
and then you know you see this with all
other artists too like kanye like i
enjoyed
college dropout or whatever but then the
direction that he is
now isn't my taste it's kind of homeless
it's a little churchy too it's a little
churchy i thought it's like a church
homeless still too i guess
i'm kind of skid row the stuff he's
doing with like the fear of god
yeah but it's i mean i don't know i
don't know
what i don't keep up anymore so i don't
know yeah like i was not a fan of her
solo stuff either like hollow back girl
and like the more rapping [ __ ] like i
liked her singing
the music videos yeah she's never
stopped being hot
i listen to the sound off anyway yeah
yeah i'm with joe because i grew up in
cerritos and she's i think she's from
anaheim
she's from she was born at fullerton
raised in anaheim yeah
so like that whole oc area i think
during that it was like
you didn't really hear much coming out
of that area
so when bands were coming out of that
area like just by association you're
like [ __ ] yeah orange county's on the
map it's being put on the map
so it felt like they were actually
representing the area
but then when she started reinventing
herself and becoming her own artist
you you started to feel like a
disconnect yeah when she started maybe
because she went from like
rock to pop yeah and also i knew a bunch
of other like bands
that didn't make it that was the same
sound like
late 90s early 2000s yeah yeah yeah when
you
she had a 90s and then when did tragic
kingdom come out
uh let me see i want to check out her
other [ __ ] was it good
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i was really glad i
left she probably was one of the
first bands to put scott on the map
i still like i still liked her [ __ ] i
heard all her solo [ __ ] i thought was
stick still i didn't give a [ __ ]
it wasn't bad i i i don't i don't think
i hated it it's just not the direction
that i liked yeah and then that's when i
started to
not listen to her anymore yeah so the
album debut
was in 1990 but that one
what was it it was no it was called no
doubt
but tragic kingdom came out wait don't
speak was no doubt though right yeah it
was
yeah no doubt the one with the orange 95
95 was tragic kingdom
i think after and she was singing at the
other guy in the band because he
dumped her and she's like [ __ ] you dude
yeah but yeah the bass player
he was still a part of it yeah that was
the cool part about it
there's so much emotion because it's
every time it's like she's singing about
them and she's turning around like [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
that's why they broke up don't speak
[ __ ] you [ __ ]
you know that was not the lyric and i
thought it was tight because uh wasn't
the bass player indian
um so i was just like this is so dope
that there's a multicultural band from
orange county which is so cool well it's
multicultural because he's the one guy
in it
true but that was more culture than if
you
that's hollywood multicultural which is
pretty good one guy having the one token
there's a lot of okay think about it
lincoln park had
um the korean dude joe was it joe i'm
mike shinoda too mike should notice
he's half yeah and then um that's also a
different time
there's a couple of rock bands that had
the token
there were 2 000 they were less featured
in that video but he's british what
about
um was it uh not offspring
uh [ __ ] with james e haw um
oasis no no [ __ ] i'm getting confused
but there was yeah throughout history
there's always been like one token dude
yeah yeah one forgotten token dude we
should do a documentary about like the
the token band member the forgotten guys
dude the ringo's of the bands
the ringo stars of the band like they
did their part
but people care about them the least
yeah they're like so what was it like
working with john and paul
you know right like [ __ ] without the
drums
there would be no music like shut the
[ __ ] up but no one cares yeah they'll be
like
without the drums they would have to
spend a few days finding another one
yeah because it wasn't like the drums
were crazy and nowadays you could just
have a drum [ __ ]
like you have the drums taken care of on
board yeah yeah
they make their job seem so bad like hey
you should be
you should be so [ __ ] privileged to
be here right now because we can find
another drummer man well dude listen to
any singer i don't know
any interview with ringo it's all just
paul and john questions the whole time
and like he tries to bring up that one
song he wrote but everyone's like yeah
that's pretty good he wrote a song he
wrote a beatles song i guess
they all did right i think they all did
yeah but but mostly it was paul and
john yeah yeah well like think about
the stereotypical like evolution of a
band right like you have like the band
and then like they can't stick together
because like they have their own
things and then like the the singer is
like
thinking they don't need them and then
they go off on their own
but usually it's the singer that
goes off yeah on their own and they can
like beyonce
uh well destiny's child they were all
three singers right
like but then like in a band band where
like
the guitarist or something they didn't
say leaving broke that band up though
single-handedly yeah
it could have been like hey guys i'm out
and they're like they're like okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay that's true who the [ __ ] is that
but all like like think about all the
bands where like the lead singer
died it's no longer that bad like
lincoln park uh sublime the sublime
because that now it's sublime with rome
rome yeah wrong
my first concert ever was sublime throne
or like uh
last year journey without steve perry
but that filipino guy
sounds like him though arnel yeah he's
good but it's just weird
because it feels like a cover band in
vegas
it doesn't feel like yeah it doesn't
feel like
that bad yeah so the voice really makes
it
yeah that's true so i think the singer
has the right
to be the dick and the star and all the
band members need to shut the [ __ ] up
geez because they're lucky okay to be on
that they're lucky to be around them
yeah
the other people write everything and
make it what it is
well then the singer should shut the
[ __ ] up because they can't i don't know
i don't know
metallica's like that the lars ulrich or
whatever is the leader
but and i don't i never hear the
interview by the lead singer i don't
even know his name well he doesn't even
talk about their music either he just
[ __ ] about the music industry
stealing his music and [ __ ]
is he still bitching about that i don't
know like people downloading their music
every time i heard him talk it was never
about the band or their music it was
always about how he's [ __ ] pissed
about napster and [ __ ] he stopped
talking about music for like 15 years
i remember they were like the lead guys
in that
era to talk about like don't [ __ ]
download my music
i work so hard for this [ __ ] feeling
from me yeah and everyone's like
okay and they just kept doing they just
kept downloading they're like yeah
yeah they're right they're singing about
[ __ ] every law
no piracy please we need some order
though
when it hurts our bank stop please tell
me hella money
i know right i don't know it's just
funny i feel like the
stereotypical band movie is so [ __ ]
hilarious too
like they'd like come up together and
then they like break up it's like
it's literally like some kind of high
school teen drama [ __ ] right
it's all the same did you see the queen
movie yeah dude
bohemian rhapsody there's several
moments in the movie because the whole
movie's about freddie mercury you know
because the phone really just the
freddie mercury movie
mercury yeah there's like three points
in the movie where freddie mercury is
like
listen guys we're all geniuses
because the band hat was involved with
producing the movies so you can tell
they want to be like no no like we all
like we're geniuses
what about the other one with um the
motley crue
that looks fantastic there's a mod yeah
dude it came out like
two years ago or something that was good
i liked it
it was good but it's it's i never even
heard of it what was it called it was on
netflix
it was with the mgk right or another i'm
thinking of something else
was it mgk he's the actor who who's the
one mgk was in what they
who machine gun kelly oh i don't know
damn i didn't know that either i was
like
kelly is in a rock band movie i don't
know he was in some movie
he was in [ __ ] a really bad movie
that everyone loved
the one you had to not see it was
horrible the one with sandra bullock
yeah i don't watch that one bird box
he was in there
you